Hallo, hier kommt das Podcast UFO. Hallo, hier kommt das Podcast UFO.
Flo, Martin und Stefan, wohl in der Düsseldessenstern.
Und zwar jetzt!
Was?
Hallo.
Okay.
Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von DPU dem Podcast UFO. Nein. Die grosse Dativ-Folge. Oh, okay. Mit dem phantastischen Stefan Klaus-Maria-Tietze. Und die Stimme, die jeder hört, ist die von dem Florentin will. Sehr gut gelernen.
Das war die schlechte Bezeichnung, das war Dativ.
Und wenn ihr gerade da am Anfang fantastisch habt, die Klänge produzieren hören, das waren Cyril und Till. Vielen Dank für dieses herrliche, punkrockige, ska-hafte Intro, das mir sehr gut gefallen hat, mit einer gewissen Energie gehe ich rein. Natürlich muss man sagen, ich glaube, das ist Tradition bei Punk, dass man nicht genau versteht, was gerufen wird, auch um natürlich die staatliche Zensur zu umgehen. Das hat natürlich historische Hintergründe, dass wenn du deine Kapitalismuskritik, Gesellschaftskritik natürlich so undeutlich herausbrüllst zu zu lauten Gitarrenakkorden. Deine Kritik an Punk wäre, die wollen zwar Gesellschaftskritik üben, aber nicht so, dass man es versteht, weil sie könnten ein Problem bekommen? Ich sage, dass sie vielleicht dazu gezwungen sind, so undeutlich ihre Kritik zu äussern, um nicht in die Fangklauen der staatlichen Zensoren zu geraten. Das ist jetzt, also das befruchtet sich natürlich gegenseitig, ein Genre, das politisch durch und durch geprägt ist. Aber jetzt hat Nietzsche ja auch gesagt, nach seinem grossen Hit Gott ist tot, Punk ist tot, das war ja sein zweiter Teil. Und ein bisschen nischiger, diese Abhandlung, nischiger. Wie würden Sie darauf reagieren? Wenn es Punk tot ist, was haben wir da gerade gehört? Von Cyril und Till. So, das ist natürlich eine Frage, denn der Punk muss notwendigerweise sterben. Als Widerstandsbewegung geboren, muss er natürlich dann sterben, den Märtyrer-Tod sterben, entweder, oder er wird natürlich sinnlos, wenn gesellschaftlichen Konventionen sich geändert haben, was, schauen wir in die Tageszeitung, nicht der Fall ist. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass er als hilflos, erfolgloses Opfer unserer Gesellschaft sterben musste. Oder ist er wieder auferstanden? Ist der Punk gestorben, um uns zu retten? Ich sehe nichts, ich sehe nicht wo. Der große Schein von Madea ist immer noch da, wo er ist. Ein Heiland hat sie nicht angekündigt, die Astronomen suchen den Himmel ab und finden nichts. Keine Wiederkehr, kein Advent des grossen Strahlemanns am Himmel. Wo ist er? Wann kommt er zurück? Ich weiss es nicht genau, ich weiss nicht genau. Fakt ist, wir haben die Festivitäten des Strahlmanns am Himmel, das haben wir hinter uns gelassen, Weihnachten ist vorbei.
Jetzt kommt Antichrist.
Jetzt kommt Antichrist Januar. Ich weiß nicht genau. Fakt ist, wir haben die Festivitäten des Strahlmanns am Himmel, das haben wir hinter uns gelassen, Weihnachten ist vorbei.
Jetzt kommt Antichrist. Jetzt kommt Antichrist Januar, da sind wir mittendrin und feiern unseren, ich habe letztes Jahr, letzte Woche, Entschuldigung, es war fast letztes Jahr, habe ich propagiert, dass wir den Januar feiern sollen, ein bisschen mehr festiv. Möchtest du dich entschuldigen für diese Auffassung? Ich will mich nicht entschuldigen, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte des Podcast-UFO.
Entschuldigung, Uldigung! Huldigung! Huldigung! Das ist ein zu langes Echo. Die letzten vier Silben. Wo, in welchem Raum befinden wir uns? Im Raum befinden wir uns, Raum befinden wir uns, Raum befinden wir uns. Nee, ich möchte mich nicht entschuldigen. Ich bin nicht mehr der Meinung, dass der Januar ein kalter Arschloch-Monat ist, den es irgendwie aufzupeppen gilt. Weißt du, das ist wie so ein Raum, wo man mal irgendwie so einen Innenarchitekten, eine Architektin reinschicken sollte, um mal ein bisschen was schön zu machen. Und da reicht vielleicht schon so eine Lichterkette oder so eine Weinflasche mit einer Kerze drin. Oder mal ein neuer Name. Wie wärst du mit einem neuen Namen? Fanua. Fanua zum Beispiel. In Österreich hat man sich ja schon vor, glaube ich, 170 Jahren davon abgewendet und spricht vom Jänner. Warum kann Deutschland nicht auch mal hier die Vorreiterstellung wieder einnehmen und sagen, nee, wir ändern den Namen einfach. Nein, Noah. Einfach mal klar sagen, so geht's nicht. So geht's nicht, du machst alles falsch. Du machst alles falsch, du bist der Vorbote des Antichrists. Interessant, ne, also ich bin ja manchmal geschichtlich unterwegs und
hab letztens... Manche sagen, du
bist zu häufig in der Vergangenheit, steckst du fest
und guckst du sehr nicht nach vorne. Stimmt,
das mag sein, aber
verblüffend manchmal, ne. Den meisten ist es aber egal.
Also ich sage, viele
sagen, du hängst auf der Vergangenheit, vielen ist alles
auf Platz eins, ist mir egal,
mit 98 Prozent,
1,5 schlecht, 0,5 gut. Fand ich immer fast verletzender, dieses ist mir egal. Ja, das stimmt. Kreuz lieber das an, was ich nicht denke, als ist mir egal. Und ich habe gelernt, dass London gebrannt hat. Eine ganze Stadt hat gebrannt. Eine ganze Stadt brennt. Alles. Alles weg. Stell dir vor, alles weg. Wann? Du willst einen neuen Ausweis beantragen. Ausweisamt brennt. Und die sagen, Entschuldigung, Herr Tietze, wir können sie leider nicht bedienen, da sämtliche Dokumente abgebrannt sind. Wir brennen. Und ich auch aktuell brenne. In Brandstecke? Ich kann sie also nicht. So to say. So to be quite literally in flames right now. Und die ganze Stadt brennt ab. Und jetzt fragst du natürlich völlig zu Recht, wann fand dieses infernalische, antichristafte Katastrophenfest statt? Ich kann das nicht glauben. Mein Mund schnellt auf, meine Wangen werden von meinen Patschehänden berührt und ich gucke dich an mit grossen Augen und frage wann, wann, wann. Eine gottesfürchtige Stadt wie London, eine so protestantisch-ethische Nation wie England, welche Strafe könnte Gott auf sie herniederregnen lassen, in welchem Jahr? Du als Drehbuchautor, welches Jahr würdest du denn sagen, ist denn das passendste? Für eine solch teuflische, schreckliche Höhe? Ja, 666. Fast ein bisschen später, ungefähr tausend Jahre später. 1666. 1666. Das ist unglaublich. Im Jahre 1666 ist London abgebrannt, wo damals natürlich die sehr götterfürchtigen Menschen natürlich gedacht haben, what the fuck? Also das stimmt echt oder was? Aber diese Zahl, 666 war immer schon ein Ding? Naja,, 666 halt. Ja klar, weiß ich, aber es ist immer so ein urbiblisches Ding. Woher kommt das eigentlich genau her, diese 666? Ich glaube, das war irgendwann mal, dass die 999 besonders gut ist, und die Umkehrung davon ist dann 666, die Zahl des Tieres oder so. Okay, aber ich dachte, das wäre einigermaßen neuer Trend. Aber okay, wenn es schon ein bisschen... Das weiß ich nicht, das weiß ich gar nicht. Aber kann schon sein, aber trotzdem unglaublich. Stell dir vor, die Schlagzeile, oder? Ja. Also, was kannst du dir noch pfiffiges überlegen an dem Tag, an dem die Stadtbrinne denkst, ja, ach was. Aber wer hat sie in Brand gesteckt? Nero. Das ist natürlich eine gute Frage. Gute Frage. Beantworte die die Frage doch mal selber. James Nero. Jeremiah Nero. Nero. Ne, ich weiß es nicht. Schreib doch mal gern so einen Kriminalroman. Mach doch mal so eine Geschichte. Wir schreiben das Jahr 1967 und der Detektiv Bartholomew J. Barth wartet durch Aschemehr London. Überall findet er noch Relikte, einzelne mit einer Silbergabel findet er. Was ist das? Deine Silbergabel? Wehmütig schimmerte in diesem Silber das fahle Licht des Londoner Himmels, der nur mehr sehen konnte, die Erinnerungen, die zurückblieben. London ist zerstört. Ich muss Lady Farnroy aufsuchen, um mit ihr das weitere Vorgehen zu besprechen. Aber warum musste er Lady Farnroy aufsuchen? Ich muss mit ihr das weitere Vorgehen besprechen, wie gesagt. Er war ja eigentlich auf dem Weg herauszufinden, wer die Stadt angezündet hatte. Ich habe schon seit einiger Zeit ein Auge auf Miss Farnroy geworfen und wollte sie wirklich gerne besuchen. Ach so, das habe ich nicht verstanden. Trotz allem, was mir gerade eigentlich im Weg steht und allen Aufgaben, die ich im Kopf habe, die es zu lösen gilt, möchte ich doch wirklich zuerst Lady Farnroy besuchen. Alle Missverständnisse aus dem Weg räumend machte er sich also weiter auf den Weg.
Doch es war schwer, den Weg zu finden in dieser Stadt, denn die alten Strassen, die er so gut kannte wie seine Westentasche, waren nicht mehr wiederzuerkennen.
Ah, doch, da vorne erkenne ich aber meine Strasse, die ist genau der Weg, der zu Lady Farnroy führt.
Er hatte sehr grosse Schwierigkeiten, sich zurechtzufinden, und so fand er nicht die richtige Hausnummer. Okay, da habe ich mich wohl zunächst vertan, aber da vorne sehe ich doch dann auch die richtige Hausnummer. Und da war Lady Farnsworth. Hallo Lady Farnsworth, wissen Sie, wo Lady Farnroy ist?
Und sie sprach, oh, sind Sie der Detektiv, der herausfinden soll, wer die Stadt in Brand gesetzt hat?
Ja, in der Tat, mein Name ist Bartholome Barth-Barth-Bartheson.
Ich möchte herausfinden, wer die Stadt in Brand gesetzt hat, aber dafür muss ich zuerst Lady Farnroy aufsuchen. Können Sie mir denn nicht helfen? Mein kleiner Junge, Bob, ist immer noch verschüttet unter dem Aschemehr. Können Sie ihn nicht finden? Wann haben Sie Bob das letzte Mal gesehen? Am Abend, als es stattfand, das grosse Feuer. Ich verlor ihn. Gab es irgendwelche Anzeichen von Bob? Wo könnte er fliehen? Hat er ein Baumhaus? Ein Treffpunkt mit seinen Freunden? Nein. Wo ist Bob? Wo ist Bob? Kapitel eins, Ende. Ja, Gott sei Dank wird auch gesagt, dass es Kapitel endet. Gott sei Dank gibt es in diesem Buch Kapitelenden, sonst wüssten wir nicht, wie wir hier jemals rauskommen sollten. Aber ganz ehrlich, weil ich... Das ist eine gute Geschichte, glaube ich. Ich werde Lady Funroy noch finden, ob mein dusseliger Erzähler das will oder nicht. Du meinst, du machst dein eigenes Ding auch außerhalb des Buchs? Oder machst du halt privat dann? Ich schreibe so eine kleine horny Story. Ach, ich wusste gar nicht, in welchem Genre hier wir wandern. Ich dachte, das wäre historisches Krimi-Drama. Ja, aber ist doch auch boring, haben wir doch auch schon mal gesehen. Bisschen Sex. Ich finde es ja eh gut, also zum Beispiel, ich finde ja, ich finde, wir haben eine Überrepräsentation von Kriminaldramen im Polizeijargon. Oh, ich will sogar weitergehen, Polizeidramen im Polizeijargon im viktorianischen England. Da haben wir auch so einen kleinen Überschuss. Das stimmt auch. Und deswegen habe ich ja einmal plädiert für eine Feuerwehrserie, CSI Firewatch. Und stellt sich heraus, es gibt tatsächlich eine. Chicago Fire? Es gibt hundert Krimiserien, aber eine Feuerserie. Und das hat mir noch nicht so gut gefallen. Ich dachte, es wäre besser, dass die sagen, hier Fußspuren, wer hat den Brand gelegt und so, aber die sind hauptsächlich an dieser Stange da. Weg da, ich will die Stange runter. Das sind hauptsächlich sehr trainierte, oberkörperfreie Männer, die an dieser Stange. Wir müssen die Stange wieder einölen, wir rutschen nicht schnell genug herunter, hol das Öl. Ähm, lieber Writers Room, ä Room, also voll cool, also wir haben auch gute Einschlagquoten, mir gefällt auch irgendwelche Richtungen. Cool, danke, gutes Team. Ja, ja, gutes Team, aber ich fände es schon cool, wenn wir ein bisschen, also vielleicht können die sich mal was anziehen, die Stange haben wir jetzt auch gesehen, so hat sie etabliert, vielleicht können wir eher in so eine Richtung, sie finden heraus, wer den Brand gelegt hat oder so, gehen. Oder sie löschen wirklich mal ein Feuer, das habe ich jetzt auch noch nicht gesehen. Wir hatten jetzt diesen elektrischen Bullen eigentlich für Staffel zwei, dass sie dann sozusagen, um zu trainieren, auf diesem Bullen hin und her reiten. Und dann dachte ich, wäre es vielleicht interessant, wenn wir drumherum so ein Becken mit Öl machen, wo die dann reinfallen und dann versuchen die sich gegenseitig zu helfen. Aber rutschen immer ab. Und dann rutschen immer ab und dann fallen immer mehr oberkörperfreie, gut gebaute Männer in diesen Pool und dann dachten wir uns eigentlich eher das. Aber vielleicht für Staffel drei, also interessante Ideen. Das geht eine Staffel lang? Das klingt nach einer Szene. Nee, das ist eine ganze Staffel. Wegen der ganzen Slow-Mo-Aufnahmen wieder, weil das fand ich auch ein bisschen zu viel Slow-Mo. Und es passiert gar nicht so viel Story und ich sehe eher nackte Männer, die sich mit Öl einschmieren. Und das ist auch nicht wirklich sicher, also die lösen dann nachher einen Brand. Dieses Öl finde ich kontraproduktiv. Damit sie schneller da sind, dachten wir uns. Damit die schneller in ihre Uniform gleiten können und dann auch schneller wieder raus und so. War das die Idee. Nee, gut, dann ... ja. Es tut mir leid, dass wir ihren Traum, eine eigene Feuerwehrserie hier nicht so richtig umzusetzen ... Warum habt ihr alle keine Shirts an? Kapitelende. Story Ende. So ist es vorbei. Ende. Also das Kapitel. Kapitel zwei, Anfang. Warum gibt es eigentlich keine ... Du kannst wahnsinnig viel Zeit schinden. Warum gibt es keine Outtakes von Hörbüchern? Sehr gute Frage. Warum gibt es keine Outtakes von Büchern im Allgemeinen? Die letzten acht Seiten, nochmal so alle Schreibfehler.
Oder so, wo der Autor schreibt, da habe ich mich so verrandet an dieser einen Stelle und hier habe ich einmal den Namen geschrieben, aber habe ich komplett.
Ich weiss, da wollte ich eigentlich voll in Akkusativ, aber dann voll in Dativ geschrieben.
Fuck!
Fuck! Und dann alles durchgestrichen nochmal, aber ich habe den Zettel aufgehoben, können wir auch noch hinten reinschreiben. Ist eigentlich eine gute Idee für einen Roman, so Outtakes, ganz am Ende. Am Ende, genau, noch so eine Szene zwischen zwei, so eine ernsthafte Szene zwischen zwei Charakteren, die dann lachen müssen. Ja, genau, so Text, Text, sorry, wir fangen nochmal an, wir fangen das Kapitel nochmal an, fuck. Mann, Romeo, Mensch, wir haben den Text erst dreimal geübt. Sorry, aber bei Hörbüchern macht es ja noch Sinn, weil da, die versprechen sich, manchmal hört man auch den Schnitt. Wenn man genau hinhört, mit guten Kopfhörern hört man manchmal den Schnitt, die sind schon noch super gut produziert und so, aber manchmal hört man wirklich den Schnitt, wie bei alten Podcast-Urbefolgen, da hört ihr auch noch den Scherenmeister. Bei Hörbüchern auch. Und da frage ich mich, die sprechen sich doch bestimmt andauernd. Ja, absolut. Es ist wie, selbst die besten Leser, Leserinnen, da verliest man sich doch manchmal bei den Harry Potter kam nach Hogwarts und es gab die vier Häuser Gryffindor, Hufflepuff, Fuck, sorry, Entschuldigung, nochmal. Slytherin und Birne. Sorry, nicht Birne. Sorry nochmal. Gryffindor, Hufflepuff, Slytherin. Slytherin. Verdammt nochmal! Alles gut, Bernd, Slytherin. Sagt mal dreimal nacheinander Slytherin. Slytherin, okay, jetzt habe ich es. Okay, und bitte. Und Harry kam nach Hogwarts und hatte dort zu Ausverteilen. Wir fangen nochmal an, direkt, gar kein Problem, wir fangen einfach nochmal direkt an. Hogwarts, Hogwarts. Und Harry kam nach Hogwarts. Sassy, wir fangen direkt nochmal an. Nimm die Stimmung mit von davor, nicht jetzt neue Stimmung machen. Es wirkt fast so, als würdest du mit dem fast gegen mich agieren wollen. Okay, alles klar. Wir fangen nochmal an. Alles, schüttel dich mal kurz. Okay. Und bitteschön. Und Harry kam nach Hogwarts. Und dort gab es die vier Häuser Hufflepuff, Slytherin, Gryffindor und Ravenclaw. Alleslaw. War das jetzt richtig? Nee, supergut. Nee, wir machen das nicht noch mal. Okay. Dann ist mir jetzt auch scheissegal, das ist mir jetzt zu dumm. Wer ist dein Job? Wenn du machst nichts... Ja, aber ich habe auch nicht unendlich viel Zeit. Ehrlich gesagt... Heißt du das Buch mal gesehen, wie dick das ist? Es ist total dick. Die werden immer dicker. Das erste, was wir gerade lesen, geht noch. Das ist erst das erste von neun, von sieben, acht, sieben. Das ist dann als Outtake mit drin. Warum hat die Stimme sich gebeten? Rufus Beck hat sich umgebracht. Es gibt sieben von diesen Müll... Hörst du gerne Hörbücher? Ich bin da nie reingekommen. Ich hatte mal eine Zeit, wo ich immer so spazieren gegangen bin, habe ich mir ein Hörbuch angemacht, aber dann bin ich immer abgeschwoffen gedanklich und dann wusste ich nicht, worum es geht. Nee, ich höre regelmässig beim Sport Hörbücher, um dann zu weinen. Während im Fitnessstudio weine ich dann.
Bei Twilight, was hörst du da für traurige Sachen an?
Nee, es ist wirklich so ein ähnliches Buch gewesen.
Also deutlich besser als Twilight, aber ich bin bei einem sehr romantischen Buch. Mit Vampiren. Ohne Vampire, aber sehr romantisch, Liebesgeschichte, stand ich dann im Fitnessstudio am Weinen. Und das Gute ist, beim Fitnessstudio wiederum, weil ja alle auch Schwitzen und so gleich gerötete, vor Anstrengung geröteten Augen haben. Beim Augentraining vor allem, ja. Beim Augentraining, beim Augenlidertraining, wo man sich so Fäden an die Augen macht. Alter, der stemmt 50 Gramm, Alter, guck dir den an. Mit Venen durchzogene Augenlider einfach, ah, zehn, elf, zwölf.
Dass man das eigentlich ganz gut kaschieren kann.
Ja.
Weil ich dachte auch so, während man das erlebt,
denkt man, was ist jetzt gerade los,
das kann man niemandem erzählen,
das erzähle ich mir in zwei Jahren im Podcast,
wenn es mir weniger peinlich ist.
Aber dann wiederum denkt man kurz darüber nach
und dann denkt man, nee, es ist eigentlich nicht der schlechteste Ort dafür. Es ist fast unangenehm an Orten, wo du gar nicht körperliche Flüssigkeiten ausströmst, da irgendwie rumzuweinen. Also es ist fast peinlich an der Bibliothek zu weinen. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass du dich beim Sport so emotional packen kannst, also dass du involviert bist. Ich dachte, das ist dann eher so, man spürt mehr den Schmerz und die Scham die ganze Zeit, die alles
übertönigend.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was das genau aussagt.
Ich mache zu schwach Sport, dass ich mich so gut
emotional auf die Story einlassen.
Ja, du hast noch zu viel emotionale Kapazität.
Macht man nicht eigentlich Sport, um Emotionen zu verdrängen?
Ja, und ich sitze da und weine, während ich mit Bizeps
trainiere. Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite
könnte ich aber auch vielleicht zu viel,
bin ich ein zu großes Sensibelchen.
Ja gut, ich finde das toll, dass du Emotionen zulässt und das dann auch genießen kannst. Was war das für ein Buch? Call Me By Your Name. Ah, okay. Das ist so ähnlich wie Twilight? Nein, nein, es ist auch eine romantische Geschichte. Okay. Aber ich habe wirklich... Ja gut, das ist verständlich. Nach dem Film das Buch gelesen, also gehört, weil ich es vergleichen wollte, gerne, auch aus einer Drehbuchperspektive. Und es ist wirklich ein fantastisches Buch, kann mir nur fehlen, Andre Assiman. Und so toll geschrieben und wahnsinnig traurig. Und dann beim grossen Finale habe ich dann da rumgesessen und geweint. Ich habe es aber nicht zugelassen, diese, also natürlich gehört es dazu, das zuassen, diese, aber du meinest gerade, du hast mir sehr viel Credit gegeben, den ich nicht verdiene, nämlich mit meinen Emotionen, um rein zu sein, um das zu genießen in dem Moment. Nein, ich habe es nicht genossen, dann da im Fitnessstudio. Du hast versucht, die wieder reinzudrücken, die Tränen. Wieder rein. Du hast versucht, sie wieder reinzuziehen. Zu unterdrücken. Ja. Nee, aber es war wirklich, es war ein cooles ein cooles Erlebnis eigentlich, rückblickend.
Und hörst du es dann auch dann zu Ende oder kannst du dann da so pausieren oder wie? Weil das ist immer das Problem für mich mit Hörbüchern, dass man immer dann wartet so auf den nächsten logischen Punkt, wo man es abbrechen kann. Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie im Zug fahren würde, zwölf Minuten und dann bin ich mitten im Satz und Harry Potter hob den Zauberstab und sprach. Aber genau so liest du doch auch. Wenn du liest, musst du ja auch irgendwann aufstehen. Dann bist du ja nicht zwangst, wie am Kapitelende. Ich lese ja nicht in der U-Bahn oder so. Mache ich auch nicht. Ach so. So, da kann ich ja dann selber entscheiden, wann ich Ende mache. Deswegen glaube ich, alles in allem Hörbücher sind überhaupt nicht meine Sache. Kommen wir nun zu unserem Sponsor der Folge. Ein paar Werbeblocke, wollte ich gerade sagen, die das Gegenteil aus. Also, nur noch mal. Mit dem Jan kann ich mich gar nichts anfangen. Ich will dich jetzt auch nicht in die Bredouille bringen. Ist die Bredouille ja eigentlich ein Ort in Frankreich? Ja, La Bredouille. Da passiert richtig viel Kacke. So, wir kommen jetzt in die Bredouille. Oh nein. Nächster Halt, Bredouille. Scheiße, scheiße. Oh, shit. Schatz, ich möchte nicht so gern durch die Bredouille fahren. Warum denn nicht? Wir beide kommen doch durch alles, haben wir doch gesagt. Wir haben gesagt, wir kommen durch jede Maloche, durch jede Bredouille und durch jede Pickel-Situation kommen wir durch. Ich weiß, unser Urlaub in Pickel war aber auch schon ein bisschen problematisch. Das stimmt. So, und jetzt, ich möchte mit dir gerne, und über den Jordan sind wir auch schon mal zurückgangen. Aber jetzt möchte ich, das war, seitdem habe ich das Gefühl, wir sind tot. Aber naja, so jetzt, ich weiß, ich möchte mit dir über den Jordan gehen. Jedenfalls möchte ich mit dir gerne, wirklich gerne an die Côte d'Azur fahren. Und ich fahre auch gerne uns dahin und so. Ich möchte nur vielleicht sagen, wir machen einen Umweg und fahren nicht durch die Bredouille durch, weil ich habe das Gefühl, da könnte was passieren, was wir nicht gut finden. Also müssen wir den Umweg über den Rubicon nehmen, oder was? Ist der bei JWD? Schwierig. Ich habe echt Angst vor der Bredouille, dass da was passiert. Irgendwas wird da passieren, eines Tages. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich genauso wie 1666. Dadurch, dass alle, ich glaube auch, dass damals in London alle so on edge waren, 1666, du denkst so, fuck, was passiert? Und das ist alle so eine hohe innere Reibung. Wie im Jahr Null. Genau, wie im Jahr Null. Wo alle denken, der Counter ist gerade abgelaufen, wir wissen nicht, was passiert. Und im Moment schreit das Jesuskind und alle sagen, dieses schreiende Baby darf uns nicht davor ablenken, dass gleich was Furchtbares passieren wird. Du, ich glaube Silvester im Jahr eins vor Christus war die Hölle. Zehn, neun, Leute, wollen wir wirklich, seit jetzt acht, sieben, sechs, null, ja null. Okay, okay, alles gut. Baby, kleines Baby schreit. Jesus, dachte ich jetzt. Es war geboren. Der ist ja nicht Silvester geboren, was ein Unfug. Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Das heißt, die haben Silvester gefeiert, dann gab es das Jahr null. Und dann haben sie zwölf Monate nichts passiert. Stimmt, und dann, wenn man fast vergisst, wenn man schon in Silvester-Vorbereitung für Jahr eins ist, wird das Jesuskind geboren, wo man schon gar nicht damit rechnet, dass in dem Jahr null überhaupt noch was passiert. Was für ein Curveball am Ende. Eigentlich ist es viel spannender als das Jahr minus eins vor Christus, Ist ja das das Jahr null in den ersten zwölf Monaten, bevor irgendein Anzeichen vom Jesuskind ist.
Aber wie lange war Maria schwanger? Also waren das klassisch neun Monate oder war das so ein, also ich meine, so ein Rein-Raus-Ding. Also ich meine, Gott hat ja aber bestimmt Möglichkeiten, sagen wir mal, Techniken, dass man da sagt, komm, das Jahr ist, äh, Chef, Entschuldigung, sorry, sorry, ich wollte nicht schlafen, ich habe so tief in der Erde. Eine Sache noch, das Jahr Null ist jetzt fast vorbei auf der Erde, wir haben jetzt 22. Dezember, Jahr Null und die Leute fragen sich in den Gebeten, das kommt immer wieder auf, die fragen sich, was Jahr Null sein soll. Sagen Sie kurz, welches Projekt, welches Projekt? Die Erde, Erde, Menschen, Menschheit. Ist das der Planet mit den Globs und den Fogis? Nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist hier, ich zeige Ihnen ein Bild. Da. Ach das, ja, ach Gott, uch. Und da müsste jetzt noch was passieren, wenn es geht, wir haben nur noch ein paar Wochen Zeit. Ja, macht mal so ein Casting, irgendwie die hottest Olle. Okay. Irgendwie, und dann kriegt die … Ich weiss nicht, ob wir dafür Zeit haben, wir haben jetzt noch zwei Wochen Zeit. Okay, dann nimm irgendwen, Maria. Okay, ja, gut, das haben wir. Okay, wir haben eine Maria. Und, also wie stellen Sie sich das jetzt vor? Hier, das ist Spritze. Moment mal, wie Spritze? In vitro. In vitro? In vitro Fertilisation, ja.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie die Spritze.
Warum muss das immer ich machen?
Den Brennenbusch waren Sie auch nicht selber.
Die Leute glauben das doch nicht mehr.
Warum muss das immer ich machen?
Glauben Sie, ich kann auf jeden Planeten runtergehen und dann immer dafür die grossen Wunder sorgen?
Nein, dafür habe ich meine Engel.
Na gut.
Michael, komm schon.
Okay, schau mich an.
Schau mich an, was bist du?
Ich bin ein Erzengel.
Du bist ein Erzengel des Herrn und deswegen mache ich die Aufgaben, die jeder Herr mir
gibt.
So.
Ich muss mir heute auch noch neun Gebote ausdenken, ich muss echt los. Was, was, was, was? Wir haben die einzige Idee, die sie beigesteuert haben, haben wir schon. Du sollst keinen anderen Gott nehmen, den wir haben. Okay. Aber die anderen neun. Nee, das ist so. Also ich wäre damit jetzt happy. Also macht die anderen noch, die anderen neun noch und so diese Füllergebote und dann, ich brauche die gar nicht mehr abnehmen. Gut, dann kümmere ich mich jetzt um das hier. Danke. Tür. Ende des Kapitels. Ende der Bibel. Ende des Kapitels. Ende des Evangeliums. Schluss. Das können wir so nicht veröffentlichen, Markus. Das geht nicht. Ich habe jetzt sehr viele Papstvideos wieder geschaut. Oh, schön. Weil zum Tode des, ähm, Bayerner, deines Landsmanns. Ja, das war unerwartet leider, ähm, ganz unpassend leider, weil jetzt gerade ja Sankt Stephan eigentlich kurz vor der eigentlichen Heiligsprechung war. Stephan, hey, das ist doch jetzt ... Nee, weil es war ein dummes Teil, ja, ich weiss. Es gab einen Link im Vatikan, dass ich und Joseph cool miteinander waren. Ja. Ne? Ihr habt euch verstanden. Es lag bei ihm, und ich will jetzt nicht kritisieren, Gott hab ihn selig, aber es lag jetzt einen Monat bei ihm am dem Schreibtisch. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange er jetzt unpässlich war. Ich glaube nur, es hätte ... Da muss er einfach nur einen Stempel drauf. Mehr will ich auch nicht sagen. Und jetzt, ja, Ende vom Lied. Aber meinst du, da kann man nicht was machen im Sinne von, der Stempel war so gut wie drauf oder so? Meinst du nicht, dass du da ... Also hast du gar niemanden sonst im Vatikan? Ich habe niemanden, ich hätte Joseph Ratzinger, ja, ich hätte Papst Emeritus Josephum Ratzinger, sonst hatte ich niemanden und jetzt, ja. Und du hast nicht, als du bei dem warst, mal so Connections geschlossen zu anderen, so Kardinellen oder so. Du kennst mich, ich bin sehr fokussiert dann auf einen und andere. Siehst du ja, wo das jetzt hinführt. Also mein Beileid. Ich habe es den Pfalzen Papst gesetzt. Allerdings. Wir alle mussten uns entscheiden, wir alle mussten uns entscheiden. Und die Hälfte der Leute sagt jetzt, uff. Naja, jetzt jedenfalls sehe ich ein bisschen schwarz für Sankt Stephan. Aber ist das nicht genau, aber ist das nicht das Martyrium, ist das nicht die Bewährungsprobe, die eine richtige gute Heiligengeschichte braucht? Einfach so, und dann wurde der Antrag abgestempelt, Ende des Kapitels, ist keine gute Abschluss von Heiligengeschichte, sondern er muss ja kurz davor scheitern, er muss ja kurz bevor er von dem Tropfen kostet, der seinen Durst stillt, muss er nochmalisse, was ist das für eine doofe Kackscheisse, dass man... Jetzt beruhig dich mal, du willst immer noch heiliger werden, okay? Was ist das für eine verfickte, gottlose Dreckskacke, dass man erst heilig gesprochen wird, nachdem man gestorben ist. Man kann ihm auch nichts kaufen von dieser Drecksfickscheisse. Okay, entspann dich ein bisschen. Das ist alles Teil deiner Erinnerung und deiner Verehrung. Das ist ja schon klar, dass das dann gesungen wird, was dein heiliges Wort. Du musst wirklich ein bisschen aufpassen. Das ist Teil des Kommunionsunterrichts. Da wird immer der aktuellste Heilige noch mal mit eingegeben. Die Welt ist nicht nur blumig. Soll ich ja ein bisschen zu viel von Messwein getrunken. Ich sage nur, die Welt daraus ist nicht so blumig. Das ist aber eine verfickte, harte Dreckswelt.
Ja, eure Heiligkeit. Wir legen uns jetzt mal kurz hin.
Sie setzen sich jetzt mal kurz auf.
Fass mich nicht an.
Gut, okay. Setzen Sie sich hin, bitte.
Ich will diese Feuerwehr-Serie gucken.
Mit den Männern.
Okay.
Wir waren in Staffel 1.
Oh Mann. Gut, es war es jetzt mit dem Stefan. Erstmal, erst, erstmal, erstmal, erstmal, erstmal, erstmal, erstmal, erstmal, wir entspannen uns, wir entspannen uns, wir entspannen uns. Jetzt hast du die Chance, richtig weiterzukommen, zu einem der besten Heiligen, zu einem der besten Heiligen, was ist deine Heiligen-Tierlist, wo würdest du sagen, welche Heilige sind Ess-Tier? Heilige, ich kenne Mutter Teresa
trifft sich da nicht?
Mutter Teresa wurde heilig gesprochen.
Nicht? Okay. Nicht? Kann sein.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich weiss es nicht. Irgendwie bist du anders
geworden, du bist irgendwie
frecher geworden irgendwie. Ich weiss nicht,
eigentlich solltest du dich jetzt mehr anstrengen, heilig
gesprochen zu werden.
Ne, man wird, sag ich dir ganz ehrlich, nach dem ersten Wunder ein bisschen cocky. Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Man wird so ein bisschen so, ich kann mir schon ein bisschen was rausnehmen. Aber ich glaube, man wird dann wieder sehr bescheiden und bodenständig, wenn man dann heilig gesprochen wird. Dann kann man sich nämlich darauf ausruhen. Es gibt bestimmt schon Leute, die wieder abgesprochen wurden, wo man gesagt hat, so geht es nicht. Das geht, glaube ich, nicht. Nee? Das geht, glaube ich, nicht. Wo dann irgendwie nachher rauskommt, dass er irgendwie London angezündet hat, Rom angezündet hat oder so und dann so, was, das war der? Frau, wie kannst du eine Stadt anzünden? Ja, gute Frage, aber irgendwie, glaube ich, brannte erst die Feuerwache ab oder so. Ah ja, klar. Und dann dachten die sich, ach komm, nee, das ist doch gemein. Das ist schon schwierig, eine Stadt anzuzünden. Das ist schon eine wirkliche Entscheidung. Ja, deswegen baut man, glaube ich, heute auch nicht mehr alles aus trockenem, sprödem Holz, glaube ich. Aus trockenem, sprödem, geöltem Holz. Wie man das da gemacht hat, mit dem Feuer in jedem Haus einfach. Ja, ich bin jetzt gerade in so einem TikTok-Deepdive. Also wirklich, ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben, weil ich habe immer Leute so ein bisschen belächelt, die gesagt haben, ich lösche diese App jetzt, die frisst zu viel Lebenszeit und so. So wie dich. Mich hast du belächelt? Ja, jetzt kann ich es ja sagen. Ich habe dich belächelt, belacht und belächelt, weil du mit deinen Instagram-Reels immer ankamst.
Und ganz ehrlich, jetzt habe ich das Gleiche mit TikTok. Ich habe das Gefühl, diese App hat mich einfach durchlasert, so wie so einen kleinen Roboterparasiten, die meine Nase eingeführt haben, oben ins Gehirn gesetzt haben, dann mein Gehirn ausgerechnet haben, gescannt haben und dadurch genau wissen, was ich habe. Dann haben die den Roboter, der kam wieder raus, in mein Handy rein und dann in den TikTok rein und hat der Welt gezeigt, was meine Gedanken sind. Diese App ist weird und da will ich, da habe ich so einen Deep Dive gemacht und da habe ich jetzt wieder erkannt, dass ich Hockey liebe, Eishockey, Eishockey, also NHL, das hat die App gewusst. Und ich hatte schon mal so eine NHL-Phase und jetzt, und aus dem Nichts wurden mir Hockey-Videos angezeigt. Und jetzt habe ich alles voller Hockey und ich dachte, ja, okay. Also das Lustige ist jetzt, weil ich war ja immer, dachte ich, der Herr meiner eigenen Phasen. Und inzwischen bin ich nicht mal mehr das. Diese App sagt mir, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das geht, wahrscheinlich, weil ich ein Hockeyvideo, was dann so kam, randommäßig zu lange geschaut. TikTok weiß, wer du wirklich bist. Ich hab das auch eine Zeit lang benutzt, und anscheinend bin ich ein Riesenfan von Tanz und Kindern. Ich hatte da schon eine Ahnung, aber anscheinend bin ich da ein Riesenfan. Also, das ist echt krass. Irgendwie das, mein grösstes Hobby.
Oh Gott.
Aber es ist das Nächste, finde ich, an der virtuellen Droge irgendwie, die so direkt an deinem Dopaminrezeptor dransitzt und so genau draufdrückt, einfach so ohne Umwege einfach dir genau das gibt, was du willst. und du bist ... das ist einfach ...
Ich musste dann wirklich aufhören und hab die App gelöscht,
weil ich hatte das Gefühl, durchgespielt worden zu sein.
Ja, hab du willst. Und du bist, das ist einfach, ich musste dann wirklich aufhören und habe die App gelöscht, weil ich hatte das Gefühl, durchgespielt worden zu sein. Wie so ein Speedrun, wo du so alles weißt und du ganz schnell durchkommst, das Spiel, diese App hat mich durchgespielt, ich kann der gar nichts mehr in den Weg setzen. Die rennen dann an den Bossen vorbei oder springen drüber und das Spiel sagt so Hey, wo bist du? Ich bin zu langsam. Und so habe ich mich auch gefühlt, wie jemand, gegen den ich mich nicht wehren kann, der nur denkt, ich komme so schnell, wie es geht, zum Ziel. Und man kriegt auch Sachen gezeigt, die man nicht unbedingt wissen will, die man mag. Wie du deine tanzenden Kinder, deine tanzenden Babys, das ist halt, will man das wissen, dass man da so ein Fan von ist? Weiß ich nicht. Nee. Eishockey, natürlich sage ich jetzt hier auch nur die entspannten Dinge, von denen es völlig okay ist, ich habe ja auch Spaß an dieser Eishockey-Phase jetzt wieder, aber es ist so seltsam, dass man da, also es ist auch teilweise echt unschön, dass man so Dinge bekommt, wo man so sieht, das ist offensichtlich, was ich mag, oh Gott, oh Gott, das bin ich. Es ist ein Spiegel, es ist wirklich ein Spiegel. Es ist ein Spiegel, ja. Es ist eigentlich wie Nehergeb. Nehergeb, der Spiegel von Harry Potter, der einem sagt, was man fühlt. Wie viele Outtakes allein um dieses Wort herum? Nehergeb. Hegib? Nehergeb, Begehren umgedreht. Wie heißt das auf Englisch nochmal? Ist nicht Desire umgedreht? Begehren umgedreht? Ne, Haggib. Eriset. Eriset. Eriset. Eriset. Eriset.
Eriset.
Genau. Mirror of ... Ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht. Ich kenne den tatsächlich nur auf Deutsch. Nehagib. Ja, Erizet. Erizet. Genau, das ist ja der Spiegel, der einem zeigt, was du eigentlich begehrst. Und das the deepest, most desperate desire of our hearts. Und das ist im Prinzip ja auch TikTok. Das ist ein der viel weltlichere Name. Es ist nicht so ein schöner Fantasy-Name wie ... Moment mal. TikTok andersrum. Kit. Kitkot. Oh shit. Kitkot. Moment mal. Ich will jetzt wissen, wie dieser Spiegel in allen Sprachen heißt. Warte mal. Aber es ist ein bisschen wie Rettern und Nattern. Ja, genau. Den Gag kann man auch nicht zu oft machen, glaube ich. Wenn du so ein Universum entwirfst, sagst du, okay, ich habe ein Gag. Ein Wort umdrehen. Und bei Nintendo dachte man sich, ja, den benutzen wir am besten für die Schlangen-Pokémon. TKR dachte sich, nee, nee, den benutzen wir am besten für den einen Spiegel in Teil eins und danach nie wieder. Man muss sich das wahnsinnig gut überlegen. Einteilen. Ja, es liegt auch in der Droge, dieser Witz. Das will ich mir jetzt auch wissen. Also, Mirror Eriset in all languages. Wow. In Icelandic it is called Draumas Begilin, which means the dream mirror. Ja, okay, aber das ist einfach faul. Das ist einfach keine Übersetzungsarbeit. Da hat es jemand einfach nicht gecheckt. Die Isländer haben es einfach nicht verstanden, glaube ich. Das ist auch so lustig, weil du konkurrierst ja direkt gegen andere in deinem Beruf als Übersetzer. Ja. Und dann als, dann checkst du, stell mal vor, dann kommst du zur Annual Harry Potter Konferenz und dann alle so, wie habt ihr denn den Spiegel übersetzt, ist ja gar nicht so einfach gewesen. Und du checkst so, dass du das nicht gemacht hast, weil du den ganzen Text bei DeepL eingegeben hast und dann nochmal so drüber gegangen bist. Aber du hast vergessen, genau hinzugucken und zu checken, dass es umgedreht Desire ist. Ja, das übersiehst du. Und dann, wie hast du es denn auf Isländisch gemacht? Das wüsste ich ja gar nicht. Fragt der Norweger dich dann so. Ja, ja. Dreamer. Dreamer. Hä? Ja, es ist doch, nein, der zeigt einem doch die Träume an. Deswegen Dreamer. Aber. Aber der hess ja eriset, desire, umgedreht. Ja, hab ich auch gefragt, was das soll, aber ich hab's den drimmirr genannt. Drimmirr. Drimmirr. Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Ich hab ihn Rakuset genannt. Warum Rakuset? Das ist umgedreht für wollen. Rekupesk. Ach so. Oh, fuck. Ich muss dringend jemanden anrufen. Wen? Stopp die Druckerpressen! Stopp die Pressen! Die Pressen laufen. Muss ich ja sagen, ist tatsächlich meine aktuelle kleine Nerdphase ist Shakespeare-Übersetzungen. Und natürlich, jeder, der Shakespeare lesen will, sagt natürlich, ich lese das Original. Klar, kein Problem, aber man versteht halt einfach kein Wort. Und deswegen habe ich irgendwann gesagt, nee, lies es einfach mal übersetzt, dann weißt du, was passiert und dann kannst du leichter das Original verstehen. Und ich bin ein Riesenfan von Frank Günther, der ist ein Übersetzer von Shakespeare und der übersetzt es immer recht cool und ganz spannend.
Cool, fetzig.
Cool, fetzig, ja, spritzig, peppig.
Im Sinne von krass, peppig. Ja, krass, peppig. Okay. Und es ist auch verrückt, was es damals schon gott, zum Beispiel diese Formulierung No Mo, ja, nicht mehr, No Mo, gibt es schon bei Shakespeare. No Mo for sure. Ja genau, das gab es alle schon. Aber ganz fantastisch, weil teilweise ist es ja übersetzt eine absolut unmögliche Aufgabe, weil du ja das, was ein Dichter macht, ist Inhalt und Form verbindet, kriegst du ja nicht hin. Ja, und Neologismen erschafft wahrscheinlich auch. Zum Beispiel, es gibt tatsächlich einige Begriffe, von denen man schlicht nicht weiß, was sie bedeuten. Die tauchen bei Shakespeare auf und man weiß nicht, was sie bedeuten. Und bis heute kann man sich grob hinleiten. Kursiv mit einem Sternchen retten? Ich glaube, ich weiss nicht, mit einem Bild, mit einem GIF, aber es ist schwierig. Eine Stelle ist mir in Erinnerung geblieben, weil da heisst es nämlich Drum, Drum, Macbeth doth come. Und du hast in dem Wort Drum, Drum klingt ja auch so ein bisschen wie eine Trommel. Drum, drum. Und das Wort drum klingt auch,
hat eine ähnliche Klangwirkung
wie Trommeln. Wohin ging das deutsche
Trommel ganz anders
funktioniert, weil mit diesem
am Ende klingt es ja gar nicht.
Also erst einmal sind es zwei Silben, Trommel.
Dann reimt es sich ja auch auf Kamm.
Und es funktioniert nicht, der Reim funktioniert nicht.
Und du hast jetzt Trommel,
das hat einfach nicht den gleichen Effekt und deswegen.
Ich habe eine Idee. Bumm, bum, Macbeth kommt rum. So und jetzt, okay, scheiße, stopp die Druckerpressen, Frank. Wie gesagt, die laufen doch schon. Was, ich kann nur sagen, was Frank Günther gemacht hat, der hat einfach gesagt, weißt du was, wir scheissen einfach mal auf die deutsche Sprache und wie die Wörter funktionieren, ich mache mein eigenes Ding und er hat gesagt, es trompt, es trompt. Macbeth kommt. Ich weiss nicht, aber er hat trompt, also trompt, ein komplett neues deutsches Wort erfunden, trompt, um diese Klangfarbe von drum, drum einzufangen mit einer Silbe, trompt, trompt. Drum, bum, bum, Macbeth kommt rum. Ja, finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Oder mein anderer Vorschlag wäre, pam, pam, Macbeth kommt da ran. Ja, kommt da ran. Finde ich auch nicht schlecht, ja. Ram, papa, tam, papa, tam, Macbeth, unser Onkel, kommt ran. ich auch nicht schlecht, ja. Ram-Papa-Tam-Papa-Tam, Macbeth, unser Onkel kommt ran. Also auch nicht schlecht. Hättest du natürlich anders übersetzt, aber das finde ich ganz spannend. Du name-dropst jetzt Frank Günther als den einen Shakespeare-Übersetzer, gibt es keine anderen? Es gibt ganz viele andere, aber ich bin großer Fan, bei der sich auch mal traut, mal wirklich mit dem Material zu arbeiten. Ja, der knetet da so richtig rein in die Sprache. Der hat da auch keinen Respekt davor, sondern knetet es mal richtig um. Und du liest dann trompt, trompt und denkst dir, was ist das? Ist das ein Outtake? Bin ich schon auf der letzten Seite? Aber nein, er erklärt dann, ja, sorry, mit zwei eingeschobenen Textseiten. Sorry, das kriegst du so nicht übersetzt. Aber ist das nicht süss, wie mit unseren kleinen beiden Nerdphasen so, du mit deinem Shakespeare-Übersetzung und ich mit meinem Eishockey? Ist das nicht, wir beiden kleinen Nerds, ne? Wir sind so kleine Nerds, da sind wir so richtig jetzt reingerutscht in unsere kleinen Nerdphasen, du mit deinem Shakespeare und ich mit meinem Eishockey und Puckmus ins Tor. Wir sind schon zwei Redetypen. Du bist ein Heiliger. Ich bin schon heilig. Ich halte noch nicht. Ja gut, aber wir beobachten das. Ich meine, es gibt auch gute Sachen auf TikTok, ich will es gar nicht verurteilen. Ich finde es auch immer ein bisschen lame, wenn man sagt, es verdummt ja nicht. Es sind super viele clevere, coole Sachen und viele kreative Leute. Aber man kriegt wirklich, wie bei keiner anderen App zuvor beobachtet, bei mir zumindest, einen Spiegel vorgehalten, was man wirklich mag. Es saugt dich aus. man kann auch nicht aufhören, es ist furchtbar. Man kann wirklich nicht aufhören und das habe ich normalerweise nicht, so eine Abhängigkeit von so einer App, so ein Quatsch, aber da habe ich es wirklich. Aber wallert mich somit TikTok zu NHL, weil das ist meine neue Phase. Ich muss aber mittlerweile sagen, ich bin fast schon in einer Phase, wo ich ein bisschen paranoid werde, wegen dieser Algorithmen und nicht, weil ich mir denke, okay, gläserner Mensch oder so, sondern einfach, weil ich vor dem Algorithmus gut dastehen will.
Und zum Beispiel ist es jetzt irgendwie spät, keine Ahnung, 23 Uhr und ich denke mir noch, oh geil, Hör ist jetzt auf Netflix. Und dann fange ich an, Hör zu schauen und nach zehn Minuten merke ich einfach, ich bin einfach müde.
Aber ich will jetzt nicht dem Algorithmus sagen, dass ich nach zehn Minuten Hör abbreche, weil ich den Film eigentlich gut finde. Und aber was wichtiger ist, ich will, dass der Algorithmus denkt, ich würde den Film gut finden. Und wenn ich den jetzt abbreche nach zehn Minuten, denkt der Algorithmus, ah, der hat keinen Bock auf Hör. Der hasst Kör. Alter, was für ein fucking Toten. Der hat es halt nicht gecheckt, der hat es halt nicht gecheckt, Der hat kein Herz, diese Melancholie, diese Sehnsucht, das kann der einfach nicht verstehen, weil der einfach zu dumm ist und zu einfach. Okay, gib ihm 1899. Und ich habe einfach gesagt, nein, ich kann das jetzt nicht vor dem Algorithmus vertreten, also bin ich ins Bett gegangen und habe den Film laufen lassen. Oh, what? Nehmen an, am Laptop? Nein, einfach Tone aus dem Bildschirm aus und hab den Film laufen lassen, weil ich mir dachte, ich kann das jetzt nicht vor mir vertreten, also das ist so, man fühlt sich schon ein bisschen beobachtet, weil ich hab da immer so eine Schaltzentrale vor mir und denk so, Chef, er hat schon wieder einen guten Film nach zehn Minuten abgebrochen. Was machen wir mit dem noch? Welchen Schund sollen wir dem noch vor die Schnauze schaufeln, dass da endlich mal was kommt? Also, ja, ich neig da auch eher zum Zweite Account, also nicht bei Dingen, wo man bezahlen muss, wie zum Beispiel bei Netflix, das macht natürlich keinen Sinn, aber bei Dingen wie YouTube oder sowas finde ich natürlich schon nicht so schlecht, da zweiten Account zu neigen. Aber du kannst bei Netflix ja auch einfach ein zweites Profil aufmachen. Ja, ich habe schon einige andere. Ja, genau. Also bei Likes bin ich da noch empfindlicher, weil ich habe manchmal so einen Bock auf so Fantasy Trash, so grottenschlechte Fantasy Trash. So Iron Sky. Und noch nein, viel, viel tiefer, viel, viel tiefer. Ah, okay. Es gibt, und bei Netflix gibt es da einiges, und auch bei Disney Plus so was wie Avalon High. Das ist die Geschichte, die Artus sage, aber in der High School. In Space. Aber in der High School. Und erst denkt man sich, okay, und es ist furchtbarer Trash, aber manchmal muss ich das einfach, brauche ich das einfach. Manchmal brauche ich das einfach und es ist ganz schrecklich, aber manchmal habe ich da Bock drauf. Das deckt sich aber ein bisschen zu den tanzenden Kindern von TikTok, also da haben wir vielleicht diese eine Seite von dir. Also, aber und da bin ich mir tatsächlich zu Schaden für meinen Hauptaccount, wo einfach nochmal schön irgendwie The Irishman durchlaufen kann, wenn niemand zuschaut. Wie, und in der Cafeteria steckt dann eine Excalibur im Tisch oder was? Das sind genau die Fragen, die ich mir auch gestellt habe. Wer ist Merlin? Der Schuldirektor. Weiß man nicht, vielleicht der Hausmeister, vielleicht der beste Freund von der Hauptfigur, welche Liebesgeschichte, wer ist der böse Drache, die aller dritter, absoluter Trash.
Wie haben sie es geschafft, Frauen in diese ja doch sehr männerlastige Urgeschichte reinzuschreiben?
Und das sind die Fragen, die ich mir stelle.
Und mit so einem Quatsch kriegt man mich.
Ich bin jetzt auch eigentlich schon sold.
Avalon High.
Er ist einfach so Highschool. Vampire haben wir schon, Mumie im Keller, hier, Arthur's Sage. Die Arthur's Sage. Ist ja quasi dieselbe Geschichte eigentlich. High School Romantic Comedy und Arthur's Sage quasi dasselbe. Finde ich jetzt schon fantastisch. Ist das eine britische oder eine amerikanische?isch. Straight amerikanisch, cool. Das ist so amerikanisch, wie es kommt. Aber ja, es gibt wahnsinnig viel Fantasy-Trash, den man gar nicht so mitbekommt, ehrlich gesagt. Es gibt unglaublich viele Fantasy-Serien. Und jetzt ja auch Willow rausgekommen, werde ich wahrscheinlich auch noch mal besprechen im Stream, mal gucken. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob du Willow gesehen hast, den Film aus den späten 80er Jahren mit George Lucas als Executive Producer, ein wilder Film, ein wilder Film mit Warwick Davis in der Hauptrolle, einem 19-jährigen Warwick Davis und ganz vielen, ganz wilden Entscheidungen in diesem Film und allein deswegen macht es Spaß, den anzuschauen, Es ist einfach, man hat das Gefühl, das war eine Zeit, wo einfach alles egal ist, einfach so. Handlungen ergeben keinen Sinn, Kostüme offensichtlich nicht für diesen Film gedacht. Aber man will doch lieber sowas haben, als wie gerade so eine von Studio Executives glattgebügelte Dreckscheisse, die gar kein Herz mehr hat. Man will doch Leute, die ihre Vision umsetzen und nicht mehr wie heute, wo quasi erstmal die Idee da ist, was man machen will. Und das gibt man dann an Leute, die gar kein Herzblut haben, die das nur machen, um danach ihren eigenen Scheiß machen zu können. Ja. Was sie aber auch nicht können und dann sind sie in so einer Spirale gefangen. Was hast du für, dass alle mehr oder weniger keine Lust haben auf diese Projekte? Ich weiß auch nicht, wie Ridley Scott das immer gemacht hat, Filme zu drehen, mit denen er nichts zu tun hatte, in der Drehbuchphase und so was. Wahrscheinlich hat er da nochmal einen guten Directors-Interpretation oder eine Directors-Fassung geschrieben oder so was, aber keine Ahnung. Das sind so Ausnahmen. Inzwischen arbeiten nur noch Leute, die, meine ich, zu spüren, nicht für das Projekt brennen. Und dann noch lieber Willow. So Aberdon High, Leute. Aber Willow, wo du einfach Ron Howard, George Lucas, die eh einfach komplett auch ein bisschen bescheuert sind. Ja. So ein bisschen auch diese Prequel-Ästhetik. Aber dieses, weißt du was man sieht, ich mach jetzt mein Ding. Ja, genau. Dieses, ich mach jetzt mein Ding und es ist alles edgy as fuck. Aber das ist ja komplett weg. Aber es ist halt auch schlecht. Also es ist halt, aber es ist auf eine charmante Art schlecht. Es ist wie wenn ein Kind ein Bild malt und du denkst, wow, wilde Figur, da passt überhaupt nichts zusammen. Aber es ist mal was, was ich noch nie gesehen habe. Aber es braucht ja Willow, um die Prequels zu bekommen, die fantastisch sind. Ja, Willow war auch relativ erfolgreich, glaube ich, dadurch, dass er auch nicht so viel ... Ich glaube, der war dann später als Release erfolgreich. Aber verrückter Film und ganz, ganz merkwürdig auf jeden Fall. Ich habe einen Podcast-Tipp für euch. Mein sehr guter Freund hat einen Podcast gestartet, und zwar heißt er Insomnicat und das ist für alle für euch, die nicht gut einschlafen können, ein Einschlafen-Podcast und das ist von jemandem, der selber ganz, ganz schlecht schlafen kann und deswegen gibt gibt es keinen besseren für diesen tollen Podcast. Also wenn ihr Probleme habt beim Einschlafen, hört InsomniCat, ist wirklich fantastisch. Ich kann auch nicht gut einschlafen. Ja, dann hör doch mal rein, ist fantastisch. Selbstkomponierte Musik läuft die ganze Zeit drüber, er hat ein Sprachtempo, was fantastisch ist. Ich sag mal, es hilft, dass er Schweizer ist und von sich auch schon sehr langsam spricht.
Gibt es auf Deutsch und auf Englisch, hört mal rein, empfiehlt es Freunden, ich hatte großen Spaß, sehr lustige Geschichten, die er erzählt. Und vor allem kann man wirklich gut einschlafen. Das finde ich gut. Ich glaube, das Schlimmste, wenn man nicht einschlafen kann, ist, sich so ein Video anzugucken, wie schlafe ich besser ein, weil das baut noch mehr Druck auf, weil da werden die Techniken gezeigt. Und eine derjenigen, an die ich mich immer gerne erinnere, das war sogar so Navy Seals, die irgendwie den ganzen Tag wach sind und nur fünf Minuten im Hubschrauber auf dem Weg zu ihrem Einsatz können sie kurz schlafen und müssen sofort einschlafen. Und da war der Tipp, wenn du nicht einschlafen kannst, musst du dein Gesicht entspannen. Und deswegen liege ich in mein Bett und ich will gar nicht wissen, wie ich dabei aussehe, immer so ganz bewusst so das Gesicht so besonnen und das Gesicht fließt so auf das Kopfkissen so schlapp runter und ich denke mir, weil ich presse ja dann, ich will ja so maximal entspannen, damit ich endlich fucking einschlafe. Du bist dann fast wieder zu angespannt. Genau, und ich denke mir so, ich entspanne jetzt so viel wie es geht. Ja. Mehr entspannen, mehr entspannen. Und es muss unfassbar bescheuert aussehen. Einschlafen ist eh so geil, weil ich denke, es gibt nichts anderes, wo man erst so tun muss, damit es dann passiert. Fake it till you sleep it, ja. Genau, weil du musst erst so tun, als würdest du schlafen. Hab ich auch lange die Strategie gehabt, ich tu so ... Ich stell mir vor, ich bin am Set von einem Film, und da ist ist ja, du schläfst einfach und dann versuche ich auch so mit so Zuckungen und so ganz dumm so zu spielen. Aber es ist die einzige Handlung, die du nur erzwingst, indem du erst so tust, weil wenn ich mich hinlege, ich tue so, als würde ich schlafen, bis ich irgendwann einschlafe. Und genau um diese Geschichten kümmert sich mein lieber Freund, ich möchte den Namen nicht nennen, ist ein anonymer Einschlaf-Podcast. Aber dein Freund, der diesen Podcast auch macht, das ist nicht du. Man hört deutlich, dass ich es nicht bin. Aber ich kann es nur empfehlen, Insomni Cat, hört doch mal rein. Hast du noch einen Tipp? Ach und ich möchte noch Banshees of Inisharen empfehlen. Banshees of Inisharen. Banshees, Shervin, on a nation. Viel Spaß. Einmal weg in Nutschen, wenn gut ist. Wenn ihr Leute danach, wenn ihr aus dem Kino kommt, welchen Film hast du gesehen und ihr müsst diesen Titel dreistig Mal wiederholen, es nervt. Banshees of Inisharen, der neue Film von dem Macher von In Bruges und Outside Three Billboards, Outside Abbing Missouri.
Zwei Liter hast du im Laufe der Folge schon getroffen.
Ich verliere pro Folge Podcast-Ufo sieben Kilo immer.
Ja, das habe ich mal gehört über Oliver Kahn oder so, dass der, ne ganz im Ernst, das hieß so, ja, weil ich dachte mir immer so, ich will auch Torwart sein, da stehst du nur rum das ganze Spiel und dann, ja, der verliert irgendwie pro Spiel fünf Kilo wegen Anspannung und was auch immer, aber konnte ich auch nie nachvollziehen, ehrlich gesagt. Vielleicht war der erst so getan, als wäre ein Torwart, um Torwart zu werden. Gute Idee. Muss man letzten Endes immer so machen. Aber deswegen mag ich, deswegen liebe ich Fussball so sehr, weil so ein Sport ist voller Mysterien, wo einfach fünf Kilo verschwinden, niemand weiß warum. Und das finde ich so klasse. Beim Fussball? Beim Fussball, deswegen schaue ich es immer so gern. Ich kann nur Eishockey im Kühlschrank. Wenn weiss, wo man NHL gucken kann. Eine neue Phase
ja, die ich mit
Stefan im Podcast
Ufo
was wird es
diesmal sein
Reiten
Eishockey
oder
brät er sich ein Eis? Schweieis. Eishockey. Wie viel Angst hat man, dass man den ins Gesicht kriegt? Gar keine Angst, weil du den Visier vor der Fresse hast. Alle? Ich dachte nur der Torwart. Torwart hat ein Gitter, Spieler haben einen Helm mit einer Scheibe vorne dran. Tolle Sportart. Habe ich einmal gespielt, damals für unsere, ich habe lange für die Jugendseite unserer Zeitung, unsere Lokalzeitung geschrieben. Und da haben wir uns immer so Challenges auferlegt, so Elton versus Simon, Joko versus Klaas mässig. Und da habe ich und Kumpel haben dann Eisdrucker gespielt mit der Frauen-Nationalmannschaft. Und es war bis heute, glaube ich, der anstrengendste Nachmittag meines Lebens gewesen. Also ich bin danach auf allen vier nach rausgekrabbelt, weil ich so nicht mehr konnte. Es war so schlimm, so anstrengend, es hat alles wehgetan, ganz, ganz schrecklich. Und die Sausen um dich herum. Es ist eigentlich Real-Life Quidditch, wirklich. Auch weil ja hinter dem Tor noch Platz ist, kann man so rum. Es ist total alles daran zu kalt. Ich habe auch einmal Eishockey gespielt, ich glaube, es war der Nachmittag am Abend, wo ich am meisten Angst hatte, weil ich besagtes Gitter nicht hatte, keine Handschuhe, nichts, ich im T-Shirt und Jeans und ich hatte konstant Angst hinzufallen und mir werden die Finger abgeschnitten. Das ist auch eine krasse Angst, die ich habe. Und das war, nennt sich Beans on Ice, kann man gerne auch nochmal nachverfolgen, war ein großes Rocket Beans TV Event, wo wirklich sämtliche Chefs bangend am Spielfeldrand saßen und dachten, bitte keine Knochenbrüche, keine Gliedmassen verlieren, weil wir hatten keinerlei Sicherheitsvorkehrungen, nichts. Aber sollten nicht Videospiel-Influencer im weitesten Sinne ihre Finger genauso versichern wie Jazzpianisten oder Konzertpianisten? Gute Frage, ja. Weil sie müssen noch WASD drücken können. Das stimmt, ja, ja. Zumindest die drei Finger der linken. Ich lasse mir drei Finger versichern. Die WSD-Tasten, Finger.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, an wie man sich da richten könnte, wenn man Fragen zur Versicherung hätte. Links auch wichtig, Daumen braucht man nicht rechts unbedingt, aber sonst braucht man rechts für die Maus. Aber gibt es eine Anlaufstelle für Versicherung, wo man solche Fragen nicht beantwortet bekommen kann? Keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, ich kenne nichts. Schade. Und die, die ich kenne, mag ich nicht. Nein, es ist Spaß. Müsst du dich mal verstehen? Was?
Ich weiss nicht.
Hast du jemals diese Verträge... Ich weiß nicht, was wir sagen dürfen. Stunde, guck mich panisch an. Wir freuen uns sehr, dass es euch gibt, dass ihr mit uns ins neue Jahr gekommen seid. Wir freuen uns sehr mit euch diesen grässlichen Monat, scheusslichen Januar. Du bist wirklich nicht mehr wiederzuerkennen. Du versuchst, wirklich genauso wie du damals von der Eisfläche gekrabbelt hast, krabbelst du jetzt noch so den Rest des Januars durch. Das ist wirklich... Hast du den Januar? Also du bist wirklich, sonst bist du ein strahlender Mensch, ich komme hier rein und du sitzt hier frohlockend, jonglierend, teilweise so hinten auf dem Stuhl, zurücklehnt, hibbelnd. Und jetzt bist du wirklich so in dich zusammengefallen, zusammengekauert. Vielleicht hilft Eishockey, dass ich Januar lieber mag, weil es kalt ist und vielleicht, vielleicht kann ich mal Eis laufen, da habe ich Lust drauf. Oh, das wäre doch schön, oder? Es gibt nämlich so eine, das mochte ich immer gern, das gab es in der Hamannstadt auch, so eine Eisfläche mit einer Disco. Also dann ist laut Musik an und dann Licht und dann Eisfahren dabei. Ist so ein bisschen so eine Achteljahre-Idee, so eine Rollergirl-Boogie-Nights--Idee, aber ich finde die total toll. Ja, als Vorbereitung für dieses Event war ich auch beim Schlittschuhfahren, aber da war es dann oft so, dass du einen so einen riesigen Kreis hast. Genau. Und alle dem entlangfahren. Genau. Und dann lernst du halt nur, wie du nach links fährst. Und am Tag des Events konnte ich wahnsinnig gut nach links fahren, aber als ich einmal nach rechts haben musste, waren meine Füße so, Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, waren meine Füße so wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, was passiert hier? Dafür haben wir nicht gelernt. Was passiert hier? Das ist nicht vorgesehen. So gar nicht. Ja, aber du kannst doch adaptieren. Meine Füße können nichts. Wir wissen, was zu tun ist links, und dann musste ich halt immer dreimal links fahren, um nach rechts zu kommen. Musste ich immer so den UPS Turn machen, dass ich immer auf die andere Seite komme. Ansonsten hätte ich es nicht geschafft. Ich bin ja im Straßenverkehr dafür, Linksabbieger abzuschaffen. Okay. Und plädiere dafür, dass man nur rechtsabbiegen darf. Man kommt genauso ans Ziel. Also nicht genau so schnell, aber man kommt genau so ans Ziel. Was machst du, um das zu erreichen, dein politisches Ziel? Die Rechtspartei? Ich könnte eine Partei, Rechtsabbiegenpartei.
Ja, die rechte Partei.
Ja, okay.
Und ihr seid fürs Recht.
Zeit, um Rechts abzubiegen. Deutschland muss Rechts abbiegen, das ist dein Parteispruch.
Wenn Deutschland jetzt mal eins muss, dann Rechts abbiegen. Gerade wir, wir sollten in Europa da die Vorreiterrolle sein, Deutschland muss rechts abbiegen.
Ich glaube, du könntest da überraschend viel Erfolg damit haben, leider. Vielleicht kommst du da zu schnell an deine Ziele und vielleicht lässt du dich von der Welle dann treiben. Also ich will nicht sagen, aber vielleicht ist das der nächste Punkt im Story-Arc, so dass in 22 war Heiliger, 2023 vielleicht vorstehe in einer faschistischen Partei und so reingestolpert. Aber ich bin so komplett irritiert die ganze Zeit und alle Videos aufnahmen, die sind so irritiert, weil ich wollte eigentlich nur, dass man den Straßenverkehr in Städten ein bisschen schwieriger machen. Und dann so Standartenparade und Verfahren und du so ein bisschen verwirrt. Entschuldigung, jetzt habe ich ich hier in meinem Programm unter Punkt 12, dass Migration gar nicht mehr erlaubt ist, aber dabei wollte ich doch eigentlich nur, dass wir nicht mehr links abbiegen können. Ja, das machen wir später, machen wir nächstes Jahr. Nee, das Einzige, was ich wollte, ist im Straßenverkehr nicht mehr links abzubiegen, um die Städte für Fußgänger und Radfahrer sicherer zu machen. Wir haben ihr Buch genau beschrieben und daran halten wir uns. Rechts in allen Lebenslagen. Kein Buch geschrieben.
Natürlich haben Sie ein Buch geschrieben. Ich habe es einem Kollegen gegeben, der hat es noch mal ein bisschen ausgeschmückt irgendwie.
Ja, mein Weg haben Sie geschrieben.
Und diese ganze Rassenideologie verstehe ich auch nicht.
Naja, der ist ja...
Der rechte Weg.
Wir sind vom rechten Weg abgekommen.
Gut.
Ja, alles so... So heißt die Gegenbewegung, endlich vom rechten Weg abgekommen. Gut.
So heißt die Gegenbewegung, endlich vom rechten Weg abkommen. So was könnte man auch machen. Alles unverfängliche Titel für meine Partei, die nur den Linksabbieger verbieten will. 23 wird ein politisch sehr verwirrendes Jahr, glaube ich. Ja, wenn wir erstmal durch diesen Januar durchkommen. Also nochmal, haltet euch an den Händen fest. Wir halten uns jetzt alle mal an den Händen und bewegen uns gemeinsam, Menschen, gelandemässig, Richtung Februar, in die Sonne.
Ist eine gute Idee, wenn du Januar eh nicht magst und auf dem Weg nach einem neuen Hobby bist, eigentlich ist Schlittschelaufen genau das Richtige, weil du kannst im Januar gut Schlittschelaufen und irgendwann freust du dich vielleicht auf Januar, weil du sagst, boah, endlich Januar, das war die Lektion, die mein Gitarrenlehrer mir gesagt hat. Du musst deine Schwächen zu deinen Stärken machen. In jedem Stück, Förentin, hör mir zu, hör mir zu, nimm die Finger aus dem Gitarrenkorbus raus. Förentin, hör auf an den Kurbeln zu drehen, an der Gitarre. In jedem Stück, und das gilt auch fürs Leben, in jedem Stück, das du lernen willst, gibt es eine schwere Stelle.
Und vor dieser schweren Stelle hast du Angst. Und du wirst das ganze Stück über nur an diese Stelle denken, nur an dieses fucking Fiss, das ich eh nicht mag, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Fernando Caroli mochte es und hat es oft in seinen Stücken verwendet. Sie haben ganz spezielle Meinungen zu Akkorden und Tönen. Und was ich dir sage ist, du musst diese schwere Stelle zu deiner besten Stelle machen.
Üb sie so oft und soönen. Und was ich dir sage ist, du musst diese schwere Stelle zu deiner besten Stelle machen.
Üb sie so oft und so genau und hab keine Angst vor dir, dass du dich das ganze Stück lang drauf freust und sagst, ich zeige euch, wie gut ich diese Stelle kann. Mach deine Schwäche zur Stärke und jetzt geh da raus und zeig's ihm dann nochmal. Geh raus und zeig's ihm!
Ja, aber geil für Rundin, das heißt die Lehre ist, ich sollte anfangen, Gitarre zu spielen. Ähm, ich will dich jetzt in deiner Euphorie gar nicht bremsen. Um den Januar lieben zu lernen, muss ich lernen, Gitarre zu spielen. Nee, es war eher eine Metapher. Das ist Fiss. Okay, ja, okay, von mir aus, tu es. Okay, du hast schon recht, das, was wir nicht mögen, ist sehr leicht gesagt als getan. Da hast du keine Angst davor haben, sondern du musst das zum Besten machen. Ja, wie gesagt, sehr leicht gesagt, Herr Lehrer. Auch dass in deiner bayerischen Kindheit immer alle Hochdeutsch sprechen. Ach du, ich sag mal, im musikalischen Rahmen, das war alles akademisch gehoben. Ach, würdest du sagen, dass Leute, die akademisch gehoben sind, keine Mundart sprechen können oder Dialekte oder was? Du willst dich jetzt festlegen? Ja. Ja. Aber es ist wirklich das Klischee, dass Leute, die Yo. Yo. Nee, es ist wirklich das Klischee ein bisschen, muss man schon sagen, dass Leute, die in Dialekten, sagen wir mal, böse formuliert, suggestiv formuliert, hängen geblieben sind.
Das hast du aber auch besonders böse und suggestiv formuliert.
Wir sagen an der Stelle Servus, haut rein und habt noch eine schöne Woche, wir verabschieden uns, denn wir fliegen dorthin, wo es keine Dialekte gibt.
Wir fliegen jetzt zwischen die Galaxis
und ja, wir müssen
noch an ein paar anderen Planeten, unsere
paar Handvoll Gags, die wir haben,
verteilen. Wir haben Orbit von einer Woche,
wir sehen uns also in einer Woche wieder
an genau der gleichen Stelle. Bis dahin wünschen wir
eine schöne Woche, bis dahin macht's gut, tschüss.
Wir heben ab.
It's a Wolfsburg production.